Die hitzewelle weitet sich zu einer schlimmen dürre aus die nicht nur die landwirtschaft betrifft auch die bäume leiden sehr unter
den hohen temperaturen und vor allem in der stadt kämpfen sie ums überleben und wir alle zusammen können etwas tun klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen
Die tabelle wird immer dramatischer nicht nur das wer
ernteausfälle von bis zu 70 prozent haben sondern jetzt geht es auch den bäumen an den kragen die ersten blätter färben sich gelb die
bäume bekommen nicht mehr genug wasser und reagieren problem vor allem in der stadt leiden gerade die jungen bäume
extremen die kleinen baumscheiben um die bäume
lassen selbst wenn es regnet kaum wasser zu den wurzeln und vor allem die jungen bäume haben dann zu wenige wurzeln die tief genug reichen
um aus tieferen regionen wasser nach oben zu pumpen hinzu kommt dass ihre pumpleistung immer weiter zurückgeht das haben forscher des max planck
instituts für biogeochemie
jetzt herausgefunden irgendwann ist der druck sogar so niedrig dass das wasser gasförmig wird und so den wassertransport
hemd wenn das in mehr als 60 prozent der wasseradern im baum passiert
stirbt er ab damit ist zum ersten mal klar
wann bäume sterben besonders davon betroffen sind eben die jungen bäume und die vor allem in der stadt sich sterben besonders schnell während der hitzewelle
hier in der straße gibt es einen solchen baum er hat es nicht überlebt aber
wir können etwas dagegen tun letztlich wurde ich gefragt ob ich nicht mal ein video machen könnte was wir gegen den klimawandel tun können und
deshalb schlug mehr johannes jojo auf instagram vor zum gießen der bäume aufzurufen also wir können etwas tun
wir können die bäume retten baum experten und expertinnen
empfehlen jetzt die bäume zu wissen dann können sie den heißen sommer überleben deshalb macht alle mit bei unserer aktion
rettet die bäume schaut bei euch in der umgebung nach jungen beugen die vielleicht sogar schon blätter abwerfen und liest sie ordentlich
mindestens sechs alba also 10 liste einmal wasser
brauchen sie pro tag macht videos postet und twittert und nominiert andere youtuber und influenza
und
motiviert jeden den wir kriegen können dann können wir ein größeres großes bäumen sterben in diesem jahr verhindern das ist ganz einfach und wir können
etwas verändern und damit ihr auch direkt zur tat schreitet gibt es jetzt keine and card sondern nur eins rettet die bäume und ich nominiere
open mind und simon will social media new york bis dann
bleibt dran